encuentre el valor posicional de tres en
cuatro mil 356 cuando me pregunten sobre
el valor posicional y mientras más
ejercicios hagan esto se volverá
automático para su mente para mí en lo
personal me gusta expander los valores
de esta cantidad reescribamos este
número 4.356 esto es igual a tener
cuatro mil más trescientos más cincuenta
más seis que esto también es igual a
tener cuatro millares o miles más tres
centenas más cinco decenas más
61 unidades regresando a la cantidad
original
tenemos que estas son las unidades
estas son las decenas estas son las
centenas y esos son los millares cuando
nos preguntan el valor por posición de
tres en esta cantidad vemos que está en
la posición de las centenas la respuesta
es en las centenas